that's a big debate is you know which
rights are universal and which rights
are are or should be left to the
discretion of countries or or in the in
the u.s. context even what should be
left to the federal government versus
what should be left to the states again
politics play into this of course
because the firt so-called first
generation rights were the civil and
political rights like the right to vote
or the right to freedom of speech the
so-called third generation rights social
economic and cultural rights which were
being pushed for more often by the
developing world and or by social
democracies and communist countries are
only slowly beginning to gain some
credibility at a global level and so
there's always been this priority and
primacy placed on the right to be free
from torture but when you start to talk
about the right to housing there's lots
of questions even amongst the Westerners
who are advocating and who have been
leading the human rights movement about
the enforceability of those rights
because the economic implications are so
substantial
you